这期视频我要介绍一个日内一分钟级别的超短线交易策略。
学会之后,你可以把交易当上班,每天重复该策略赚取收益。
请确保你一定要看完这个视频,因为我会提到一些重要的点。
如果你不注意这些细节,你可能无法成功地运用这套策略。
我们首先将图表设置成一分钟级别,然后选择你喜欢的交易币种。
我一般会选择主流币交易
比特币或者以太币
这套方法适用于任何交易市场
包括外汇、股票、期货、加密货币
唯一的要求就是
你选择的交易对需要有足够的交易量和流动性
因为这是一套超短线交易策略
我们要保证在不会遇到滑点和流动性不足的问题
在这套策略中
使用到了三个交易指标
我们打开指标
搜索ADX
将它添加到图表中
这是一个度量价格趋势强度的技术分析指标
ADX的数值越大表示着趋势越强劲
我们点击设置
将平滑和长度都改为15
然后我们在ADX数值20的位置添加一根水平线
如果没有设置在20
可以双击这根水平线
在坐标这里
把数值改为20就可以了
然后再添加第二个指标
我们搜索NDN Oscillator
这是一个震荡指标
可以看到后面有一个EP,是TradingView上的精选交易指标
我们将它添加到图表中,并使用默认的设置
最后一个指标是TTM Squeeze Pro
这个指标是一个类似MAC的柱状指标也使用指标默认的设置以上就是我们这套一分钟超短线交易策略所需要用到的全部指标下面我来讲解一下该如何去使用指标默认的设置。以上就是我们这套一分钟超短线交易策略所需要用到的全部指标。下面我来讲解一下该如何去使用它。
这其实是一套非常简单的交易策略。
相信聪明的你一定可以学会并使用它去获利。
首先这套策略中最重要的一点是去观察Squeeze指标的变化。
可以看到在中轨上有四个不同颜色的点。
绿色、红色、橙色和黑色。
我们不用在意橙色
黑色和红色点
只需要关注绿色的点就可以
因为当绿点出现在指标的下轨区域
就是红色和黄色柱状的区域
代表着提示我们可以进场做空
但这不是直接进场方式
我们还需要通过另外两个指标去做判断
当绿点出现在上轨区域
就是浅蓝色和深蓝色的区域
提示我们可以进场做多
上面这个NDN震荡指标
它是由三根线所组成的
橙线、红线和绿线
当红线穿过橙线在三根线最上方的时候
代表着可以进场做空
当绿线穿过橙线在最上方的时候
代表着可以进场做多
但这些都不能单独地去判断
还需要杰和其他两个指标在进行交易
ADX最后一个判断条件
当X的数值在20的上方
代表当前市场趋势强劲
可以进场做交易
上面就是这三个指标不同的判定方法
但我们需要将它们结合在一起
下面来讲一下如何去进行交易
如果你想找到一个大家一起讨论策略和行情的地方
欢迎你加入全台湾最大的加密货币免费交易群组
我们有最完善的教学课程和免费的报单讯号让你的交易之路不再单。首先我们要观察这里绿点是否出现,比如在这一段行情中,绿点出现了,
同时这个绿点是在指标的上轨,柱状是浅绿色。
意味着这个指标提示可以进场做多,然后我们再去看NDN震荡指标,
可以看到绿色穿过成线,同时红线在最底部,也提示了可以进场做多,
接着再观察ADX数值是否在20的上方
就是我们一开始绘制好的这一根水平线的上方
看到在这里绿点出现的时候
X的数值还在20的下方
所以我们暂时选择观望
等价格再走完两根K线
这里的时候
X突破20
痛时绿线还在最上方
标记点也是绿色
我们就可以进场做多
止损放置在这个位置
指引可以选择指损位1比1或者1比2的位置当作指引点
最后到达了指引2的位置
我们再看这里
出现了绿点
同时柱状处在下轨
提示可以做空
震荡指标红线在呈现的下方
虽然X在20的上方
但这三个条件是缺一不可的
所以这单我们不能做空
虽然在后面红线短暂穿越过了呈现
但此时绿色的点已经消失
判定条件不成立
这个位置绿点出现
柱状是红色的
同时在下轨
第一个判定条件成立
震荡指标的红线穿越了呈现
是做空信号
第二个判定条件成立
这时ADX的数值还没有超过20
说明现在的趋势较弱
我们等待X的数值超过20再去做单这根K线X数值超过20第三个判定条件成立其余两个条件也符合我们的数值超过20再去做单,这根K线,X数值超过20。第三个判定条件成立,其余两个条件也符合。我们进场做空,止损就设置在这个顶点,指引按照盈亏比,1比1,1比2来设置。
这里价格最终到达目标位指引2,有一个你需要注意的细节,比如这里,绿点出现,柱子是蓝色。
指标符合做多条件
X数值在20以上也符合条件
震荡指标的滤线在呈现的上方
按理说也是符合条件
但是你需要注意的点是
滤线是在这个位置交叉穿过呈现的
这个交叉状态已经持续了很久
这种情况出现
做单的胜率就会降低
如果你在这个位置选择入场
那你将会直接买在价格的最高点
最后亏损出场
所以如果条件符合
尽量要在绿线或者红线刚刚穿过成线的时候进场会好一些
再看这里
绿点出现
柱子蓝色
指标符合做多条件
X数值在20的上方
也符合条件
但是绿线没有穿过成线去到上方
这时就不能做多
后面绿线穿过了成线
但X的数值走到了20的下方
就意味着这单不再符合条件
后面价格也一直处在震荡当中
所以一定要满足所有条件在进行交易
这样不仅可以保证交易胜率
也可以更好的使用这套超短线交易策略
在仓位管理方面你也需要注意
一定不要重仓进行交易
把交易当做是一个工作
细水长流才能更长久的在这个市场中活下去
这期视频就到这里
记得订阅点赞
并打开小铃铛
我们下期见